wenn ich bin fast drei videos mit habe
ich bin sofort folgen blieb
hey ich bin so folgt herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video ich bin seit einer
gefühlten ewigkeit mal wieder hier an
meinem alten aufnahme platz wenn er zu
hause bei meiner familie zum ersten mal
seitdem ich ausgezogen bin und ich werde
heute mal etwas verspätet auf einen
trend aufspringen und zwar auf den
irgendjemand bewertet youtuber trend
habt ihr sicherlich irgendwo schon mal
gesehen aber ich möchte das heute auf
eine andere art und weise machen zwar
werde ich mir auf chatroulette leute
suchen die irgendwo auf dem anderen ende
der welt sind und diese läufe youtuber
bewerten lassen ob die sympathisch
aussehen oder nicht ich würde sagen wir
reden nicht lange rum sondern starten
direkt los bitte hören sie auf damit
ich würde sagen wir reden nicht lange
rum sondern starten direkt los und
hoffen einfach mal dass ein bisschen was
gutes dabei umkommt dass mein herz meine
wäsche waschen mit checklisten ok
wertvoll ist gespannt wie halt raus also
ok also anscheinend findet sich dagegen
nicht sympathisch auf diesem foto züge
gen erwarten das lachen ist und wissen
ort findet sie auf dem tisch auf den
ersten blick ich will jetzt die leute
gar nicht irgendwie beeinflussen in
ihrer werbung zu sagen manipuliert ihre
zuschauer oder was er sage tanker okay
fried ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen würde
dass die biene süße stimme hat ich
glaube er nicht
leister lifestyle würde ich sagen lassen
wir durchgehend around the really have
no idea what kai nowitzki max
was sagen wissen jahre alte schwedin von
meinem pong ball kracht wenn don't know
how wird keine ahnung wie fühlt sich nur
what the [ __ ] also dieses bild hier okay
gut ja er guckt also ein bisschen
verdutzt gattin wenn du es das sei nicht
böse gemeint also nur bilder von der
google-suche genommen und da sind halt
keine coolen integration kommt voran
yakin hands auf den ersten blick weniger
sympathisch als da gebiet jessie j wenn
du ist immer da die chimera speed okay
wie denkt dass ihre videos macht wie ich
wirklich nicht ganz sagen ich mache mir
auch ein bisschen entertainment videos
würde ich groß betiteln schaffen macht
fashion and take much of fashion
gaming sessions youtube preis
er sagt ja relativ sympathisch ich
glaube hier keine gemacht ist laut gfk
also er sagt er findet das ganz gut
aussieht aber er sieht keinen grund dass
man so perfekt gemachte haare hat wenn
man sowieso zerrissene jeans trägt and
no anscheinend finden die rimini
sympathische okay okay gesagt auch das
eher sympathisch ist er häufig weg da
drüben wiedergänger flott dj dreht die
macht ein bisschen was in die mixed
richtung auflegen also dj kid blogging
macht er auch
verbrechen rostock feiert schon feiert
aber es ist wirklich so
also eher schreibst du katja förster
eindruck kein kommentar
[Musik]
die fashion beauty richtig lustig alter
er sagt ich mag videos gegen abschluss
da muss man ihm jetzt zugute halten dass
man halt echt nicht damit rechnen dass
katja macht schreibt germanwatch
präsentiert sein erstes lachen glück
okay leute ich hoffe dass wieder hat
euch gefallen dass es mit abstand das
video an dem ich am längsten gedreht
habe es war zwar nur drei leute aber ich
habe zwei stunden lang aufgenommen
ich hoffe mal das video hat irgendwie
auch irgendwann gefallen ist oder sonst
was
[Musik]